since 1995 the electronics Entertainment
Expo has been the mecca for gamers all
around the world it's a week where
developers and console manufacturers
alike shared their roadmaps for the
coming year and beyond in short it's a
week where millions of us around the
world sit in front of our computer
screens and watch really weird press
conferences a top 10 most memorable
moments list can really go one of two
ways either we concentrate on industry
defining moments or embarrassing stage
performances that will forever live in
infamy hell why not a little bit of both
here are top 10 most memorable moments
from e3 past you'll be sucked first up
number 10
well bam there it ain't when Kudo sonoda
isn't headlining corn he loves playing
with his Kinect or rather his project
natal as it was known in 2009 so who
better to demo the new tech of
Microsoft's e3 press conference what
happened next was probably the most
appropriate demo Kinect could ever get
fantastically cool technology that just
doesn't work you ever wonder what the
bottom of an avatar shoe looks like what
BAM there it is bam bam bam there it is
BAM number 9 a surprising cameo in 2010
a certain PC developer head had been
pretty vocal about his issues with the
current generation of consoles
especially Sony's so it was a pretty big
surprise when Jack Tretton Ouellette
GLaDOS duty honors applying surprise in
three two
I've been pretty outspoken in my
comments about the current generation of
game consoles never before as an e3
crowd when so amazed to see a white
millionaire take the stage number eight
I hope you're wearing news clothing it's
time for very very exercise all I
remember of economics 2010 press
conference was frantically calling all
of my friends while wiping tears of
laughter from my eyes I don't really
want to get into specifics on this one
but just oh man it's just the boss so
good
hi Kurama is talking dancing to a few
new rebel so wait you tell me that's
gonna be dance dance evolution dance
dance abortion no no and about always
armies of the more than 1 million troops
1 million troops we will dance with
absolutely no control 1 to proceed the
same button like x axis and y y ax and x
x and y v again you'll be sucked you'll
be sucked
baby Express number seven Nintendo's
living room revolution the Nintendo
Revolution what was later to be known as
the Wii was revealed in 2005 but
Nintendo's e3 2006 presentation was
perhaps the most wondrous and
enthralling press conference to grace
the annual Expo there for the first time
we saw Nintendo's new motion based
console and full effect
we saw playable demos of Mario Galaxy
Twilight Princess there was Reggie being
Reggie Miyamoto in a tuxedo some weird
stage flap thing des was killing it and
he finished it all off with a demo of
Wii Sports bonus points for allowing
random audience member to play the game
live on stage remember having an open
mouth for most of this and if nothing
else it's a reminder of how at least for
once the rhetoric of a company on an e3
stage was actually delivered to gamers
number six kills one gamer zero you know
what in retrospect we probably should
have known better but in 2005 the latest
consoles were making some pretty
good-looking games so at least it seemed
plausible that Killzone 2 could actually
look this good unfortunately and
eventually guerrilla games admitted this
was all CG but at least for that moment
we could dream
number five the best and worst console
launch of all time number five comes
from the first ever III console
announcements have always been a staple
of the Expo but few others can top
Sega's bombshell in 1995 the Saturn had
been slated to be released a number of
months after the conference and fall but
at e3 Sega of America president tom
kalinske and answered it would hit the
store shelves
the next friggin day this gave Sega over
years head start on the n64 but the
early release both pissed off retailers
and caught off developers so the four
console didn't have much in the way of
software for a while a contributing
factor to its eventual demise and that
of Sega's Hardware hopes number four
shots fired by newcomer Sony III 1995
was a real doozy
that same year Sony a company who most
people associated with really expensive
televisions than tape players entered
the console market with their
PlayStation the Saturn was to come out
the next day at a price point of 399
dollars so how would Sony react in their
relatively short keynote address Sony
exact Olaf olafsson invited SCE a
president Steve race up to the stage and
he proceeded to drop the mic
nine in the last three the bronze medal
the biggest cheer of them all if he
weren't already bummed out about
Nintendo's not having a conference this
year
here's another reminder of just how
amazing their conferences can be in 2004
Zelda fans were divided over the
aesthetic of the most recent game in the
series Wind Waker the Nintendo community
recording every realistic looking 3d
Zelda and going into e3 rumors that one
was already development or rife the
Nintendo Conference was almost finished
when right at the end they showed off
just one more thing
ah Miyamoto you're just the first number
two giant enemy console price attack its
weak point for massive damage I mean
it's almost as if Sony we're trying to
win a top 10 most memorable press
conference moments as if they were
trying to make as many reasons as
possible to win such a list the
PlayStation 2006 conference gave us so
many memorable moments hot plastic
naughty bits so you know what there's
something missing and I tell you what
that is and that's a wing mirror and I'm
gonna give you a very special
demonstration of a wing mirror but very
special demonstration of a wing mirror I
knew that this rapid order was crazy
the stages of the game will also be
based on famous battles which took
actually took place in ancient Japan so
here's this giant enemy crab and you
attack its weak point for massive damage
and after almost two hours of
unimpressive pimping of their console
that was left port Kaz Hirai
to drop the ultimate bombshell the
second Sony price heard around the world
and this time not a good one the 60
gigabyte playstation 3 for five hundred
and ninety nine US dollars six hundred
and fifty nine dollars Canadian oh so
knee you swing so hard in both
directions but it's time for number one
can you guess what it is yet
you know what I may take some flack for
this but you have to remember where our
industry was this time last year
Microsoft my favorite console
manufacturer of the previous generation
had gone on full attack mode against
consumers earlier that fateful Monday
they showed off the Xbox one a system
was a host of policies that nobody had
asked for and always online console so
much DRM that it was pouring out of the
blu-ray drive everyone was waiting with
bated breath to see if Sony would decide
to fall in line with their rivals attack
on used game sales but not only did
their announcement make the collective
gaming world breathe
massive sigh of relief it started a
narrative of Microsoft backtracking that
would continue for the entire year for
instance PlayStation 4 won't impose any
new restrictions on the use of
in addition playstation4 disk space
games don't need to be connected online
to play
so those are our top 10 most memorable
moments of III s past but I'm sure
you've got plenty of your own so let us
know in the comments below or hit me up
on the tweets and don't forget GameSpot
are going to be at e3 this year as ever
we're going to be showing every single
press conference live plus dozens of
game demos live on our stage show all
week long so make sure you join us then
for plenty more memorable moments